We ask them now, okay,
has it gotten better? And very few people say that it has.
In fact, many say they feel it's gotten worse
and inflation is the reason that they say that.
But what's also interesting is we ask them, okay,
look back to the economy during the Trump years,
how do you remember it?
And majority say they remember it as being good cause
they forget about the pandemic.
Well, they seem to be skipping over the pandemic.
And that's exactly what that tells you in their memory of this.
But it also explains now when you ask them, okay,
now let's look forward, they say
more
say they feel they'd be financially better off under Donald Trump
and that cuts directly to vote
and that is helping the former president.